Northern California man is behind bars
and his wife is out on bail after police
say he tortured their 10 children over
at least three years police removed the
children from the couple's Fairfield
home in March that's when investigators
say officers discovered filthy living
conditions including floors covered by
animal and human waste
Jamie yuccas has the disturbing details
I don't know what they even mean about
torture I have no idea
I know Rodgers denies that she and her
husband Jonathan Allen ever abused their
10 children but on March 31st she called
police to report her oldest child
missing when they arrived officers
encountered nine of the children ranging
from four months to 11 years old living
in unsafe and unsanitary living
conditions police say they found garbage
and animal and human feces Rogers was
charged with child endangerment the
children describe incidents of
intentional abuse resulting in puncture
wounds burns bruising the injuries
consistent with being shot with a pellet
gun or a BB gun Jonathan Allen was
arrested six weeks later after the
children told police about his alleged
mistreatment he pleaded not guilty to
seven counts of torture and nine counts
of felony child abuse
he's being held on a 5.2 million dollar
bond
she has been advised for legal and
constitutional rights the case is
reminiscent of another California family
in January David and Louise Turpin
pleaded not guilty to torture child
abuse and other charges for allegedly
starving and shackling their children
ina Rogers says her family's case is a
misunderstanding
we are gonna fight to the end until we
get them back and we are cleared of all
these crazy allegations Allen will face
his next court appearance related to the
charges next Thursday for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas